yeah what's something you haven't
accomplished musically that you want to
accomplish um i most definitely want to
win everything that all the musicians
before me want like grammys and
you know just vmas i feel like we need
some of that and that's it and just keep
making good music more platinum records
more number ones
so i know you produce as well and i was
talking to my friend gabe who is
somewhere he's right there um before
this interview just things that he want
to know from about you
and he was like okay see these gabe
questions yeah yeah this one is gabe's
question i liked it i was like i'm gonna
ask americans
yeah
he said okay so if we gave migo or if we
gave quavo and the migos this like
old-school type beat
and he can put three people on it what
beat would you choose like it's a sample
what beat would you pick and who would
the features be
are old school
no i think new school people
old school people too yes okay uh mo
definitely be a james brown beat
um
any one of those beats because he must
definitely had the hip-hop sound
um
who would i get on it uh
i did so many songs with so many people
uh i get jay-z on it
i get jay-z
kanye
and
uh in drake
jay-z kanye and drake all on one song
i'm sure that would be a interesting
song yep for a variety of ways but i
mean i think if three of those people
are on a song i don't really think you
it could go wrong the final product
wouldn't go wrong i don't know about the
creation of the song but the final
the final product though it's gonna take
a long time to come out but we can't
lose it'll take a long time to come out
for sure but uh what's it sound like
what's it sound like i'm not asking you
to rap this time but it's giving me what
what that song sounds like because i
think it's really interesting that you
produce but i don't feel like you talk
about the fact that you produce a lot i
don't know what it sounds like i'm just
if i'm just the producer i just wanna
i'm gonna just cook the beat and i just
want you to just lay this track i just
want you to just go in you got to come
to the studio so you don't know a lot
about me you got to yeah i don't know
about the studio i'm a sports i'm a
sports team music you just say the words
you got to come in and watch still have
you ever been to like um
benny hunter yes of course yeah i'm
saying the bocce bus you did what i'm
saying they cook it in front of you
so we cook it in front of you you know
what i'm saying you can watch it
you can watch me cook it in front of you
okay we got your chicken your steak
your fried rice extra egg no vegetables
okay stir-fry
got to cooking like a stir-fry
and that dj the real gonna make the beat
yeah oh my god
that's the season what is okay so you
talk about the studio tell me the
experience of being in the studio at
cueva i've heard a bunch of things of
what it's like to be in the studio with
dj khaled i hear it is just luxurious he
does whatever and it's just a great time
with cueva no my studio session is
not like that at all okay
i wouldn't come no more no i'm scared
it's not like that
it's just some good vibes all of us in
there
it's very cloudy you know um okay
the room is very cloudy do you write
better high
i just said the room is cloudy i write
better do you write better when it's
cloudy i write better in the sky
yeah okay i write better in the sky and
um
and um i just make sure like i just made
sure that
somebody got some crazy beats and then
i'm just ready to go like when you see
me you'll be like damn that [ __ ] crazy
because you really make a song in 25
minutes yeah make a song in like 25
minutes i only got to do the first hook
in the verse the rest of the boys come
in and go crazy yeah and vice versa they
do the same